il arrive dans délégation lycée mont
gerald du marin ce sont les instigateurs
du désormais gingrich engineering liche
en français dans le texte
enseigner l'anglais est enseigné en
anglais en fait l'idée de ce concept
d'éducation et d'instruction
intitulée parcours anglais plus a pour
objectif de faire de l'anglais une autre
langue courante en martinique un projet
validé et développé par le rectorat
l'idée fondamentale c'est quand même de
sortir de l'école primaire bilingue
donc ça pour ça il a fallu évidemment
innover avec des méthodes innovantes
surtout rassuré la communauté
notamment des professeurs pour quoi il
pouvait enseigner l'anglais mais
également enseigné en anglais et c'est
vrai qu'après une expérimentation sur
trois trois bassins en réalité ça c'est
vraiment diffuser bien au-delà de ce
qu'on pensait un projet porté surtout
par tous ces enseignants présents dans
la salle
l'anglais n'est pas leur matière de
prédilection pour parfaire la langue ils
n'ont pas hésité à partir suivre une
formation à barbade pendant les vacances
scolaires à leurs propres frais et les
vrai qu'au départ c'était pas facile
c'est assez difficile pour moi avec mon
anglais de collège et offert moussa a
été habitué avec la sonorité de la
langue etc
je fais du sport en anglais et là je
trouve qu'il a énormément de mieux en
mieux
de quoi le sport en anglais par exemple
la dure un peu d eau one-stop slowly
voilà ceci en place dans la troisième
mais prépare métier donc l'ancien 3e
prépa pro est en fait donc ça ça démarre
par des petits exercices notamment
sciences physiques et surtout en suisse
les chiffres parce que c'est plus simple
avec cette matière en faisant des
petites études juste des petits
exercices en anglais donc des petites
phrases donc les élèves se prête bien au
jeu et il arrive facilement à comprendre
les consignes parce que les consignes
sont assez sains près de 2000 élèves une
vingtaine d'établissements scolaires
sont concernés par parcours anglais plus
le recteur évoque déjà parcours créole
et espagnols plus la caravane de
formation s'arrêtera en décembre au
lycée trinité du françois et en janvier
elle sera au lp ou de bellefontaine